we are in nature and we're a part of
nature so the idea of saying well i'm
not going to respond to my environment
like you are the environment the way of
looking at reality is as if you can just
create this wall between reacting
completely to what's happening out there
it's like you're out there too you know
it's like someone that's in traffic and
that guy hate all this traffic it's like
you're trafficking
yeah and so that way of thinking to me
is unrealistic and doesn't really follow
through all the way
corey allen welcome yes sir thank you
thank you for having me in your city
it's my absolute pleasure thank you for
coming to the city i know man it's been
very good it's been a shame that we
haven't got to see each other until now
for professional purposes but we've
we've made it work we've spoken
previously a lot about mindfulness
you've got still my favorite ever guided
meditation course and
i wanted to try and have a discussion
today where we can help people who are
into mindfulness who practice it when
they can or practice it regularly
to try and take
their
theory and the work that they do during
their mindfulness practice
off the cushion so to speak into the
real world try and get some practices
some triggers
some examples of how people can stay
mindful and create the mindfulness gap
in their everyday lives whether that be
with family when emotions arise during
situations to help them feel more
present and mindful and live a life
which is richer
and also to be able to distance
themselves from their emotions to stop
themselves from identifying with things
so
why would you start let's say someone
comes to you and says corey i want to
try and take my practice off the cushion
where would someone even begin yeah um
well i think that the the first place
someone would start would just be
focusing on their actions like their
physical actions more
uh with more intention right so just
paying a bit more attention to as you're
going throughout the day
like not just letting your hand do
something sort of by its own but
actually as you're going to pick up your
coffee mug or whatever just notice the
fact that it's happening just notice it
happening and notice the feel of the cup
and tap more into the sensory experience
of your experience more often
you know and by doing that even you know
of course
doing that with your own breath during
throughout the day um but even whenever
you're walking just
note the fact in your mind i am walking
oh i'm walking there's a foot you know
planting planting planting interesting
you can and you whenever you start by
doing that what you're doing is
basically tuning yourself in to the
sensations within your sense doors you
know all of your your five senses
and then the plus one which is the sense
of consciousness you know in buddhism
there's they add that as a sixth
sentence mental formations and for a
good reason which i can share later
um
but essentially getting tuned into how
you're you know just being in a body in
the world and being aware of what you're
experiencing when you're experiencing it
that would be step number one
because even focusing on that alone that
simple thing like take make it
completely secular take away all of the
all the other stuff that meditation or
mindfulness may have to offer and even
take away all the insights
pluck some random person off the street
and say hey
try this as an experiment pay a little
bit more attention to
just your your sensory navigation of
your day and just see what happens
and what happens is that and a person
can't help but not you know the mind
begins to train begins to focus more on
that as opposed to being caught in this
this
what most people are caught in that live
an unexamined life are this automatic
causal type of repercussion momentum of
of life to where
they have all their their you know their
programming the chance of their life the
happenstance of where they were born who
their parents are the experiences that
they've had and so forth and so forth
and
what happens is that in all that
conditioning you know the conditioning
of kind of what you should think who you
should be how you should whatever
um you just go along kind of reacting to
everything that you experience
and in that
people spend a lot of time unfocused in
their their mental area just their
general conceptual view and connection
with their the present moment of
experience
and because of that
because there's no focus on this it's
all kind of this drifting sort of um
mental kind of junkyard of stuff that's
happening up there just lack of focus
ultimately yeah um one thing that i find
quite interesting and it's nice that you
touched on touch as the first one
you know one of those days where you you
notice yourself being lost in your own
thoughts it's almost like you're walking
through your own dream
in a weird way and you're very much just
on automatic mode one of the things that
i do it happens sometimes when i'm
driving in the car
is try and grip the steering wheel and
feel it's got little perforations on the
leather steering wheel and just really
really try and get very very clear about
how that feels underneath my hands it's
so strange that that seems to pull me
out of it but
john viveki guy canadian psychologist
guy has
some really nice experiments that you
can do around this so
everybody most people
that are listening are wearing clothes
right um but you don't feel the
sensation of the clothes on your skin
unless you focus on them let's say that
you've got a pair of shoes on you don't
feel the pressure of the shoe around
your foot you don't feel the seat
underneath your bum you don't feel the
ground underneath your feet you don't
feel the wind on your skin you don't
feel the breath in your lungs
all of these sensations are there at the
forefront of consciousness ready for you
to tap into ready for you to feel
present
look at how much how many layers there
are and i've just named some clothes
that people wear some items that are
attached to their body you can feel the
tent that the sensation of a t-shirt
that's just pushing on the front and on
the back of your body it's there all day
how is it that you don't notice it
that's because you're not paying
attention now would it do for you to
spend your entire day lost in the world
of your t-shirts pressure on your skin
might be a sub-optimal way to live your
life however
it shows that that is there for you at
all times and that's such a cool
practice i mean i need to do that more
yeah absolutely and really um you know
we're kind of jumping out a little bit
but the
the focal point that one wants to get to
after a period of mindfulness and
meditation training
is
finding this this buoyancy between the
macro view of self just kind of the
overhead view of like oh i'm a person
that's existing in a body and the highly
focused view like as you mentioned of
like oh what's the sensation of my
t-shirt only
the real sweet spot is in between those
things and continued practice makes it
to where the transition between those
two states is extremely not only natural
and fluid but instinctual as well so if
you read the actual original mechanical
commentaries on
mindfulness training which is a very
small part of a huge
dialogue
a way to describe it is if you're
looking at a tree in the distance
you want to be as focused on the tree as
you are in the field as well equal
balance on the big picture and the
individual thing and that as as it's a
truism but it's also as an analogy to as
you're going throughout the day you
always want to try and be focused on the
big picture to a degree and then in an
equal balance with a focused precise
point of attention and focus but
allowing
having the relationship between those
two things be such that it shifts
instinctually based upon what your
response is into your current moment
experience how can someone bring more of
that into their life yeah well
meditation certainly is a key a key way
because first most people are stuck in
um focus mind but it has no aim so
they're sort of zeroing in on one little
tidbit and then another tidbit and
another tidbit and another tidbit and
that's where people feel like whenever
someone says oh well my my mind is crazy
i have too many thoughts going on i
can't focus on anything i'm thinking i'm
80d or you know whatever someone might
say that's just because they're leaned
way into
this ultimately what it is is it's a
panic state that's where most people are
is because if no one if a person doesn't
train themselves in whatever modality
that they have to move the body over to
a parasympathetic nervous system state
then they spend all their time in the
kind of amygdalae
fight-or-flight or fight-or-flight
adjacent state and that's where most
people are because
being as i was saying earlier being in
the state of conditioned awareness and
conditioned mind of what you should
experience what you should think how you
should act to x y z or what someone says
that also goes to just the contents of
life as well so people are continuously
just reacting to everything all the time
instead of engaging with it with a sense
of self-awareness
and
um
ultimately
whenever you you are in this panic state
because there's so much stuff especially
now with you know social media and just
all the technology stuff there's so many
things to focus on is if people are just
going from one thing to the next thing
the next thing the next thing and what
happens is that's really just juicing
the amygdala brain part of the brain
like an orange and so you're in this
panic reactive state all the time that's
like people that say oh well i'm i'm an
achiever i'm crushing it all the time
i'm doing i'm working like you know 4
a.m to 10 p.m i have 9 000 meetings and
all this stuff i'm doing all these
things i'm really like feeling good and
doing it's like no you're caught in a
panic state because you're going from
one thing to the next thing the next
thing but you're mistaking the
the um
like serotonin release of constant
low-level craving like basically taking
a bunch of like a thousand little tiny
hits of a drug over and over but you're
not actually
feeling you know really good you're just
kind of like a rat hitting a feeder bar
in a lab experiment right we spoke about
this earlier we were talking about the
fact that now the most important skill
that you can have in the 21st century is
to be able to filter information you
don't need to be able to scavenge for
more there is more information than we
need the smartest people on the planet
are the ones who are actually able to
effectively discern noise and signal and
spread those apart right that's what
people need to be able to do and i
suppose that on a personal level as well
you need to work out okay what are the
stimuli that i want to have in my life
what are the things i want to continue
to allow in one of the ones that i want
to get off so we've got
a somatic practice or a focus on the
body
what is it that i'm sensing
doing that connecting with that i'm
picking up this glass how does the food
taste how does the fork taste and feel
in my mouth etc etc what would be the
next step yeah so then
actually moving to some type of like
sitting practice i think is really
valuable
and i know you mentioned taking off from
that but in terms of what we're talking
about here this is someone who has no
mat at all right
so
let's say even if someone doesn't want
to say well i want to start meditating
as you mentioned just let's parse out
some of the noise right so having a
moment of time in your day that's
scheduled in if you have to where you're
shutting down the phone you're shutting
down the computer you know in turning
things off just having a space of quiet
and stillness that you can exist in for
you know however long you can what would
you prescribe for someone that is is
keen to do this the people that are
listening will be familiar with
mindfulness practices yeah some people
will have a
semi-regular one that they wish was
probably a bit more regular i would
imagine that that's a big chunk of of
the audience so
what would you say is your prescription
to try and aim for how long how frequent
yeah i mean i if you can't at least half
an hour i mean that's what because you
think about like people think that
sounds like a lie like it sounds for
half an hour but you know
someone will sit down and watch a half
hour you know episode of something on
netflix or whatever and that's a half
hour you know it's not that long and
there's time that that fits into the day
it's just about dedicating that time to
that or you think about before bed or
after like i know some people a lot of
people that they wake up the first half
hour of their day is just reading or you
know and so you can plug these things
into life and really just having that
time in there what it does is it just
starts to desaturate the senses you know
but and it stops it
takes away some of kind of the chewing
gum that them that the intellect has
where it's always trying to focus and
having something because if you're
always engaged with a phone or a social
situation or some type of entertainment
then what you're doing is you're really
ignoring the your inner self right
because you're always just you're
externally involved with something else
it's a form of distraction and that's
how people stay so
intensely plugged into those things is
because
they're they're staying intentionally
distracted oftentimes from something
that they don't want to acknowledge or
they don't want to feel you know so it's
a goal if i go if i go out six nights a
week i never have to think about why you
know i feel whatever whatever way though
i'll never forget i was in a
relationship with a girl while i was at
uni and we were breaking up it was my
choice and she was upset and she was she
said something to the effect of
um
i don't want to go back to having to go
out all the time
and that blew me away because implicit
in that is if i'm not with someone i
can't bear to not go out all the time
right and that scared me and that really
made me i mean one thing it said was
[ __ ] this was the right decision because
if this person has
if they struggle so much with being on
their own with not having a sense of
validation personally that they then
need to go and get it sort of publicly
yeah that's a
pretty malignant
part of their life uh but it stuck with
me man that was
[ __ ]
12 13 years ago just some random tiny
little line
i don't want to have to go back to going
out all the time yeah it's so crazy how
stuff like that sticks with you you know
i always think about this think about
all of this stuff all the interactions
that you've had with people on your
podcasts in meditation sessions when
you've met somebody in the street
and some throwaway
[ __ ] line that you just decide to say
someone could keep with them for 60
years for no reason it might not be
profound yeah that one was like a
profound insight but it could just be a
thing the funny way that you said
fortune or whatever you know like just
some random [ __ ] it's so mad how that
happens we don't know the uh
legacy
that our interactions carry with them
another reason why mindfulness is
important because you're more aware of
what you're saying when you're saying it
and so you're not
the chance of saying one of those things
with a positive effect is much higher
because you have this intentionality
about what you're saying as opposed to
just talking [ __ ] freely and you know
maybe you give someone the wrong idea
based off of just something that you're
carelessly saying and then they take
that as a script to move forward you
know i was just recently reflecting on
one and this isn't really connected to
anything other than how those little
kind of ear worms get into your brain
and just i was recently thinking about
one of those
um
so probably like almost 20 almost 20
years ago at this point i was working in
a bookstore and to find see if this
bookstore had a particular book you find
you look it up in one system and then
there's like a 10 digit number and they
typed that into another system that
would show you if you had or not so
there was an older gentleman that was in
there and i was you know like
19 or 20 or something
and he said you know do you have this
someone i looked and i got a pen and
paper because i found that number i
wanted to write down and he goes oh he's
a holder i said what are you doing i
said well i got to write this down so i
can put in there it's like no no you can
you can do that like let's think for a
second like it's it's ten numbers or
whatever like
what look at them what are they like
remember them you've got you know five
seven nine whatever and they say you can
tell we can totally do this and i was
like okay and i remember i i did it and
then i remembered them repeated them in
my mind and then typed them in and like
boom got it right and for whatever
reason that just stuck with me where i
was like hold on a second like i
shouldn't default to just
not engaging with my intellect in my
brain in moments because
i either think it's not possible or
you're just oh well you should grab a
pen and paper why it's one of those
conditioning things it's like because
it as a group in society it's something
that people default to saying you should
grab a piece of pen and paper
instead of um just
you know kind of leveling up a little
bit and engaging and saying actually i'm
going to i'm going to apply my mind to
this man life
life needs to be lived by design not
default because so many of the default
settings that we've got are horseshit
they're so bad
and
i don't know whether you do that i
imagine you pro
imagine that you probably do um did you
ever as a kid make little games for
yourself about how quick you could get
up the stairs oh if i can get up the
stairs this quickly or maybe if i can
jump over if i can go up in twos or
whatever it might be oh yeah well my
well go ahead just those those little
things kind of like that i do that as
well i try and come up with dumb
dumb little tests yeah for something
i've got to remember a string of numbers
for somebody's phone number and i'll go
out of my way to make it not a big deal
but kind of like a little a little
challenge for myself but that's the same
compulsion that i had as a kid while i
was saying well if i if i throw this
basketball in on the next three girls
then i'm going to become a millionaire
whatever it might be you know that sort
of dumb stuff yeah yeah definitely i
used to this sounds weird saying it out
loud but that's why i'm sharing so when
i was a little kid you know you play
with your toys in the bathtub perhaps um
if you're lucky enough to have such
thing
and uh as a little kid i would get
um like ziploc bags you know like just
plastic bags and i would get like a toy
and i would put it in there and i would
put food coloring in there and i would
get packaging tape and a swiss army
knife
and i would play surgery
so if i could cut the bag open and
extract the toy with like not leaking a
certain amount of red colored you know
water and then tape it closed all under
water then i was like a successful
surgeon
and look at you now a successful surgeon
successful surgeon yeah if you have
anything you need taken care of all that
preparation has really done well all
right so we've got the somatic practice
we've got making sure that we've got
intentionality when we're doing things
when we're actually engaging with our
mind yeah we've got a seated practice
which you've said for about half an hour
i think personally for me
half an hour really pushes the limit i
think that i worked up from 10 to 15 and
then 15 to 20 and as i start to go over
20
i'm like wow this is a that goes from it
being a something that my compliance is
high to something that my compliance is
lower but that's even just like sitting
like laying in bed without anything
okay happening yeah i'm not talking
about privatization yeah just just yeah
just stillness just quiet like shutting
out the noise because that's for someone
that doesn't want to try and meditate
just like turn off the static for a
while every day you know that's really
cleansing to the mind and that will
actually draw your awareness
inward because this is one of the big
things is that like when if you're
always engaged with like content or data
or some type of distraction you can't
hear your own voice
because you're always thinking in
relation to whatever the other thing is
and so shut all that out and think well
what what am i thinking right now not
what am i reacting or whatever to
you know because you're co-regulating
your your consciousness by constantly
being engaged with external material yes
yes dude here's an awesome hack for that
just drive in the car without any music
and without anything in your ears this
was something that i started doing when
i went to
i would the drive to the office is about
15 minutes and it was so good
i'm already driving i'm doing something
which is sufficiently system one that i
don't really need to think about it
right you're not thinking about driving
when you're driving unless you're really
bad driver and there are some awful
drivers in austin i'm gonna segue austin
has
the most barbell strategy of drivers
i've ever met in my life everybody is
either an ex-rally car driver or
a danger on the roads that shouldn't
have a license there is no one in
between there are people that are
amazing and people that are terrible but
um
driving to work
with silence is
so good and you're doing the drive
anyway and it's sufficiently passive
that it's probably not going to matter
that's a great way to do it i think yeah
no that's a that is a good way to do it
and so the point of doing all that would
be to start to withdraw somewhat from
the continuous kind of panic mode of
always dealing with something and give
yourself a chance to slip into that
parasympathetic mode right so by doing
that you then that's the rest and digest
zone where
you become
less
frantically focused on things less kind
of anxiety driven and reactive and more
calm full you know more serotonin is
releasing more self-aware heartbeat
slows down breath becomes more shallow
you know and in that state
um
you're of course feeling good that's
where most people would like to be and
that's ultimately after you meditate for
10 minutes or whatever that's where you
what you'll typically switch over to
um but doing that getting into that
state consciously through
even just shutting out the noise or some
type of formal meditation practice even
just the easy breathing practice
that will begin to bring balance because
if you're always in that fight or flight
mode all the time messing with a bunch
of noise
it's just going to introduce a
counterbalance to that state and draw
that one back a little bit and the more
that you practice those and the more
time you spend in that state of
stillness and mindful awareness the more
balance that those things you know more
into balance that those two things are
going to
become
how happy would you be with someone
doing this alongside a fairly menial job
so let's say it's driving the car doing
the washing up mowing the lawn are you
happy with somebody utilizing that time
or is there too much stimulus going on
if they're doing a task um as long as
they're focused on the task i mean that
could that's definitely a mindfulness
practice yeah chalkboard carry water
yeah but apply suggestion number one
that we had to that moment so getting
into the awareness of your actual
experience as you're experiencing it and
being aware of the sensations and the
sense stores and so forth
while having that you know just
something to focus on
is is a good way to do that as well
thinking about how overloaded
i
sometimes am but also some of my friends
are
ridiculous at this they'll be listening
to a book on three times speed whilst
the roomba automated schedule is going
around and hoovering up the house and
they'll be cleaning things up but
they'll have their laptop open because
they've got some notes for an exam that
they've got coming up a little bit later
on i'm like
the
threshold the water line
for acceptable
stimulus has just shot through the roof
you're already listening to something at
a million times speed you've got this
schedule thing going on you know you've
got to call in five minutes but you're
going to fit this in because
yeah the um i don't know where that
compulsion comes from i i think it's
partly productivity more done in less
time
stuff but i also think that you're right
that
there is an anxiety
beyond i should be doing more with my
time there is
simply an anxiety with just
sitting yeah without excitement yeah
yeah yeah it's because if you if you
haven't done it before you know then
all the stuff that you haven't seen you
kind of start reacting to because you
you feel like oh well now you become
aware of your internal dialogue and what
you're actually sensing it's just
overwhelming because you're used to
numbing it by being distracted away from
it you know
what's next well
um
from there i'm gonna go to
just uh
something a bit more fun and it's a bit
more more deep but um it's a fun thing
that people can do to really begin to
get to the root of
something that will be very helpful so
along with the sensory input of
uh just experiencing what you're
experiencing in a physical way with more
awareness
start paying attention to throughout the
day to
your your movements and what kind of
what you choose to move how you move
your hand what you're actually doing and
again just note those things in your
mind as as you're doing them so you're
sort of like oh again i'm lifting the
cup you know i'm setting the cup down
i'm walking i'm talking right now and
you can do this as detailed as you want
this is actually a part of the
fundamental training of mindfulness
as far as it's actually written is to do
this but a monk would do this 24 7 for
you know however long for for weeks
years months whatever it's very very
detailed and that's all you're doing is
noting um but the point is is that the
more that you start doing that and you
focus on just kind of noting your own
awareness being aware of your own
experience
then something interesting starts
happening
is that the time it takes because you'll
you'll stop doing that and then at one
point later in the day you'll then go
you kind of catch it again and remember
and see like oh yeah yeah i was noting
things so now now i'm i'm getting some
food or whatever it is right um famously
uh spinski i believe it was gurgis
disciple
uh
went out to he was doing what he called
self-remembering same concept just
different school of thought
and was walking and he was
self-membering and things were going
good
and then
uh a few weeks went by he had to get a
pack of cigarettes and a few weeks went
by and he said oh yeah i was
self-remembering until i went to go get
that pack of cigarettes you know so even
someone who's doing it in this train
that you could you could start it and
you'd be doing it and then something
will kind of sweep you into this long
chain of thought so much that a lot of
time could go by but eventually you'll
remember it and you'll go oh right i'm
going to do that thing and you start
doing it again
and then the more that you focus on that
just the more curious it becomes how
how you're not really
as in control of yourself as you think
you are you know we're very much these
autonomous kind of beings that are on
autopilot in a lot of ways in our lives
you think of the amount of times that
you shift your feet around while you're
sitting in a chair or you scratch your
arm or you go to have a sip of water or
you lift your arm up or you kind of move
a thumb across the fingernail or
something like that or you blink
whatever it is there's all these things
that we do constantly that we're that
we're not even aware of we're just
engaged whatever with whatever kind of
our focused mental mind is
on at that moment but when you start
doing this practice more you'll start
noticing how much
that you're actually doing without
realizing it you'll notice how you're
shifting in your chair you know you'll
notice all those little movements and
stuff like that and what gets really
trippy is that then
you start to notice like something for
the example of oh if your arm is itching
if you were completely unexamined you'd
be sitting there at your office or um
your arm would itch you would scratch it
and you wouldn't even think about it it
would happen way way in the background
if you're noting your
your present experience you'll notice oh
i just scratched my arm that's
interesting cool and then as you
continue practicing this
as time goes on
then you'll get to a place where you can
if you so desire to go deep into it of
oh my arm is itching i want to scratch
my arm now
instead of just going oh i just
scratched my arm i'm gonna go oh there's
an itch there interesting and now we get
to a deeper level of it which is
the arising
array of impulses that we have because
our impulses are really the root of all
of our behavior
and whether you you note your physical
movements enough
you then can go backwards one step or
deeper one step and realize
the rising desire and impulse to do
things as opposed to just the fact that
you're doing them
and what that does is gives you one
level deeper of control and awareness of
your actions and how you're existing in
the present moment
and all of this really boils down to
being able to navigate
put a sale up on the boat of your life
and navigate your existence with more
intentionality and more self-awareness
and what's interesting is if you watch
this example say you have the itch and
you notice the impulse to scratch then
you realize you have agency within that
you go hold on i i don't have to lift my
hand up to scratch it right now i can
choose to respond to that or to not and
i can actually just kind of focus my
attention on that itch feeling like what
is that really it's just an odd little
sensation it's really not unpleasant
it's just there
but i'm so conditioned to mechanically
automatically and engage with it that
i've always done it but if you just
watch it and you keep watching it and
then it just kind of goes away
like huh and the more you start getting
into that level
then you realize that that awareness of
the impulse to do things not just as
you're doing them
you you become
more in in control of
everything in life like like eating per
se you're not stuffing your face you're
actually aware of what you're eating
you're aware of well
this a rising impulse to just crush
whatever's on your plate or go like you
know i'm actually gonna i'm already
getting full i'm gonna stop now because
i'm full i don't want to feel sick later
if you're talk speaking with someone and
you
have these words arising in the
directions that you want to change or
move the conversation or the interaction
with
normally a person who is unexamined is
just kind of you know they're they're
going going it's all unraveling against
their real will it's just kind of just
happening to them almost a person and
that's why people say things they regret
they say harmful things they say kind of
unskillful things as one would say
or just stupid things you know
but with that deeper level of mindful
awareness you then like the same
awareness of the impulse to do a
physical action as opposed to just doing
it you become aware of the arising
dialogue in your mind and what you're
going to say and if you should say it or
not and that's really where that
mindfulness gap appears that you
mentioned earlier because
then say that you have a a reaction to
an experience someone says something
that triggers you and you get irritated
and you feel normally you would react
and say something cutting or mean or
like resentful to them
um
with that level of clarity and
self-awareness and intentionality
you can then feel that feeling arising
and then actually examine and know what
you're going to say you know more
skillfully if anything at all and like
what the moment actually calls for
as opposed to being drawn into
a further detachment distraction of that
panic and anxiety state yeah man i think
about an example sam harris uses a lot
while he was sat at a meditation retreat
and
if you have tight hips like
almost everybody you sit on a meditation
cushion your knees can hurt a fair bit a
good bit of
force going through them and he said
that he focused on the pain in his knee
for so long until it broke apart and it
became sort of pure bliss and i've been
going to a place called which i need to
force you to come with me at some point
uh hot and cold therapy sauna gets up to
250 degrees which
is a hot puppy
and then they've got
34 degrees fahrenheit cold plunge
straight outside you go and you lower
yourself in and there's a little clock
on the wall
and um
very quickly after starting to do that i
noticed that
if i focus on the sensation of what cold
feels like not on being cold not on the
narrative around the fact that this is
cold and this sucks and i've just come
out of 250 degrees and now i'm into 32
degrees
if i focus on the sensation
everything completely changes it's a
fascinating experience that kind of
feels like tiny little needles tiny
little pin pricks and then it feels like
a vice and now it feels like warmth and
now it feels like something else but it
doesn't feel like cold
cold is the narrative name that we've
given to that particular combination of
sensations if you actually get into the
sensation itself it breaks apart into
components that
like a meal
right you eat a meal if you're not
focusing on the meal you're just eating
the the aggregated macro flavor overall
but if you really really pay attention
you go okay well that's the chicken
that's the oregano that's the pesto
that's the spice that's the pot
and you can break it apart in that way
and um the richness and the level of
depth i mean you can see how much i'm
desperately trying to stay in for three
minutes that i'm going into some black
hole
of uh mindfulness just to try and stick
about for 180 seconds but
it's awesome for
cold therapy
has been
you know those whatever i've done maybe
30 between 20 and 30 three-minute blocks
since i've been here in that cold plunge
and every single time it's fascinating
yeah i'd like to do the cold plunge in
the sauna oh you think no no
um
uh yeah i know that that type of stuff
is
that's almost like manufactured uh
external intervention you know where
you're shocking the system and to
forcing your attention onto something um
which for someone is useful for anyone
it's usually a useful experience but
also for someone who just feels like
they can't break out of it it's like
well they're they're always oh man put
yourself put yourself in that cold
plunge and think about something that
isn't what you're doing yeah so paul
bloom's most recent book the sweet spot
is great and he interviewed a dominatrix
for it and he was trying to work out why
it is that some people and
suffering is part of a good life and how
pain sort of contributes to our sense of
enjoyment
and
this dominatrix said nothing captures
attention like a whip
what she means is that if someone slaps
you in the face
for the next three to five seconds
you're not thinking about anything other
than the fact that you've just been
slapped in the face
and it's not that people want peace of
mind it's that they want peace from
mind
can i enter into a state it's one of the
reasons that i think people love
extreme sports that have a very very
high chance of death you know base
jumping wingsuit downhill mountain bike
snowboard ski
all this stuff
it
forces your attention into such a narrow
chasm
because you know that the problem and
the issue of you straying from that is
so grave that you may die
and that's peace from mind not peace of
mind right
exactly and it's it's kind of
fascinating that there are so much
easier
ways to get to that place than
getting squirrels diving a wing suit and
jumping off the side of a mountain
um but to reach their own um yeah i
think going a little deeper and moving
into
a really useful aspect of
what we're getting to here with with
this being more aware of what's going on
in the mind what's going on starting
with the body being aware of the senses
and then starting to move into the
mechanism of the mind
if you you keep following that you get
to you know one of the places you
mentioned where like well these are
rising things these impulses these are
just fabricated concepts that don't
really mean anything you know i'm just
like resonating like a wine glass you
know with someone singing but there's
not really that material the conscious
material that's arising
that's not me those are just mental
formations you know so even whenever you
you want to say you go wanna i need to
go check my email real quick like that
impulse you see it arise that the
feeling to go go into motion and check
the email it's like well that since
that's just a complete passing cloud of
nothingness
you know and being able to distinguish
that those are really coming from
nowhere and going to nowhere will show
you that your thoughts are really not
you right you are the awareness is
observing the passing of the thoughts
the witness to the content of mind not
the mind itself
and understanding that is so valuable
because one of the things that people do
is mistake their thoughts for who they
are and that leads to an extensive
amount of
self-criticism of self-doubt self-hatred
um all sorts of things and really just a
true confusion about the nature of self
and reality
an example that i have been enjoying
using lately to describe that
is
um
imagine if you are
there and you you have a nice orange
nice tasty orange you open it up you
smell the orange right
you smell it for a moment and while
you're eating it or whatever and then
you carry on about your day
for hours later you never mistake that
you were the smell of the orange
you're well aware that you smelled an
orange
that was the smell you moved on it moved
on and it's not not there anymore right
but with thoughts
what happens is that a thought arises
someone looks at that and they go oh
that's who i am or that is some type of
truth
and then because it's internal and sort
of external they're then able to
grab onto that and then relate to it
right to their identity to that thought
of that sensation and that's much more
insidious and long-lasting because it's
internally resonant as opposed to
externally informed so
with this the smell of the orange we're
aware that that is outside of the our
skin there is a tactile world and in
that there is stuff happening and our
senses taking the information from that
world and we recognize that there's a
relationship between our experience and
that external object and there's no real
confusion there in general right
but the issue is with the we're getting
the reason why that's so clear is
because we're getting constant feedback
from the external object right
um like you always know your arms are on
a table because the table is always
pushing on your arm you know there's no
mistaking like i'm becoming the table
like it's it's there it's there i'm here
right
and so um
with with the mind since those things
are generated internally whenever a
thought goes by
there's no resonance there's no
reference point there's no constant
feedback it can just hang in
the space of the mind's eye right and so
then because often our thoughts have to
do with us because we're thinking about
our own narrative and kind of creating
our story of whatever's happening in the
moment
we can we begin to mistake that
mental material you know
for
truth
and for reality and for what we are so
if someone has this thought you know
some type of like ah i'm a piece of [ __ ]
like i shouldn't have done this goddamn
i'm a you know and i'm failing it like
this thing or whatever
that thought arises and then you can
grasp on to it because it's it's kind of
suspended in space in your mind and then
you look like an endless orange yeah hit
the endless orange of self-hatred and
self-doubt and then you that that gets
kind of grafted onto the lens of your
experience and then the longer you stay
with that that begins to then inform
your decision making in life because
your temperament has changed you know
your your outlook on the self is
changing so therefore your confidence
and your general navigation of your own
life changes and it also just becomes
the snowball of suffering because the
longer you stay thinking that that is
real and true the more real it will seem
because the mind is always naturally
looking for ways to reinforce whatever
it's currently thinking at the moment or
whatever it's experiencing trying to
build the case or my our consciousness
is always like litigating reality at all
points right
and so in 12 a jury of 12 of your peers
who were all other aspects and layers of
the self are all you know voting to
convict constantly and so
um by recognizing
that the conscious material that's
arising in the mind is simply just
disconnected
happenstance truly just transient sort
of data
you can then step back and observe that
and not get caught up mistaking what you
think for who you are
yeah man
thoughts not being things is
it's so easy to forget
um do you have any more stories or
examples that you like to use with the
people that you teach about how to
remind themselves that
thoughts aren't things
oh well i mean that's that was a pretty
good one i just shared but yeah um i
just i'm just trying to think if we've
got the orange we've got that idea we've
got
i'm just wondering if there's if there's
another another way that you like to
frame that yeah so you could think about
something more simply because i know
that was complicated and exhaustive
something more simply
you think about like
how
say you you are you wake up in your bed
one morning right and you feel great you
didn't have any drinks a prior night you
ate well you slept well you feel good
the sun is shining in the window smells
good and fresh in there beautiful crisp
day there's a little owl outside your
window looking in at you he's happy
belly full of mouse the everything is
good in the world right you get up you
feel good all right i'm gonna go this
beautiful day i'm going to go out i
can't wait et cetera et cetera you go on
now
say that the next that night because you
were having said you could not decide to
celebrate right now you're going out
with you know with your friends
you're having
30 drinks or whatever it is
you're eating cheeseburgers at 4am and
then a pizza
you get into a fight of some kind
you know someone glasses you in the head
with a bottle you know whatever
then
you decide to have a glass of sand
instead of a glass of water before
getting in bed
we've all been there
so you get in you wake up the next
morning
headache shattering pounding splitting
headache eyes are blurry that sunlight
now is like giving you this crazy
headache it's contributing oh god pulls
the curtains closed you know now the
smell in the room you're now smelling
sour to you because now everything has
got this kind of pungent repulsive smell
everything makes you a little nauseous
uh the colors in the room now hurt your
eyes as well and seem distasteful and
disorganized you have no energy you know
for the day you don't want to get moving
none of that stuff and you just want to
land your sweaty bed and just lay there
and just rot right with this this
headache i'm in the bed feels lumpy you
can't get comfortable you know all this
stuff
now think about the fact that
that room
didn't change
the room a person you had those two
distinct experiences in was the same
same room what was different was your
mind and what was different was the your
your frame of consciousness your state
of mind in the way that you're
perceiving it because of what was going
on in your body at that point in time
now that's an extreme example and what
i'm doing here is peeling apart the
subject and object relationship of mind
so
what we experience and what we think
about experience is
we we receive all based upon where our
mind is at that point in time and how
we're thinking and how we're feeling
right
and so as far as the thoughts or not
things go
if you
a good practice to
notice you know kind of uh
the the true nature of that is to
pay attention to
a
thing that you're experiencing whenever
you're feeling good and how you project
your feeling on to that situation versus
an experience where you're feeling bad
and how you project your feeling on to
that situation as well with a negative
light a disruptive light versus a
positive or an optimistic light
and then as you start realizing that
you're really kind of projecting the
story of how you're feeling onto your
experience
then try to separate that it's easier to
do it if you're in a good mood realize
like oh i'm feeling good this room is
great blah blah blah these people are
nice and just stop for a second deck
well
am i enjoying this so much or am i just
in a good mood you know like is this
really the best wine i've ever had or am
i just was i looking forward to it you
know and you can start to just notice
how the difference between the way that
you're thinking versus
what really is would you say i think if
you run that forward the stoic
uh
stoicism's prescription would be
something along the lines of
the external environment should never
impact your internal state now to me
given the fact that
most people are trying to find a route
to happiness and joy and flourishing in
life that feels a little bit like you
wake up on the great day and the owl's
full and
everything's going fine but the stoic
would remind himself
this is
no materially no different to the day
when i woke up with a hangover that
feels a little bit like constantly
trying to build up a fire someone coming
and throwing kerosene on it and you say
no no no i don't want that
how do you
factor in the ability to be sufficiently
robust is to be able to deal with bad
situations but also um
absorbent enough that when you have a
good time that you utilize that as a
catalyst do you ever do do you get this
tension that i'm talking about sure sure
yeah and that's why i think stoicism is
um has a lot of incredible you know
beneficial qualities to it but at the
end of the day it's quite repressive
you know
um
because the reality is is that no matter
who you are you're always going to be
affected by your external environment
it's just the fact that we're hairless
little monkey creatures you know like we
are in nature and we're a part of nature
so be given i mean the idea of saying
you know well i'm not going to respond
to my environment like you are the
environment
you know that the way of looking at
reality is as if you can just create
this wall between reacting completely to
what's happening out there it's like
you're out there too you know it's like
someone that's in traffic and that guy
hate all this traffic it's like you're
trafficking
yeah yeah you are too and so
that that way of thinking to me is
unrealistic and doesn't really you know
uh follow through all the way
and so it's realizing you know in in
those moments the fact that you always
are going to be flowing with what is but
it's just about and this really is the
crux of all the stuff we've been talking
about
putting enough effort into being more
self-aware
being aware of what you're thinking in
the moment that you're thinking it being
more aware in the present about your
actions and the choices that you're
making
and using your intentionality to then
make choices
towards you know the direction of who
you want to be or what you want your
life to be like and in that comes
you know interfacing with the the truth
of whatever your environmental
circumstances are at that moment and
using the information there along with
your self-awareness to then continue to
make intentional choices
what about emotions
because that's like a not a particular
thought not a narrative you know a felt
sense yeah a phenomenon that arises how
would someone utilize
taking mindfulness off the mat
to be able to give them that mindfulness
gap when an emotion arises yeah i mean
that's a really viable one because
emotions are like the ultimate you know
no no logic a lot you know if you can't
it's tough to be very emotionally very
logical at the same time um so people
tend to do things very you know brashly
whenever they're getting really
emotionally
um or getting really emotional rather
and so mindfulness is super valuable
because it takes some of the heat and
the impact off of
negative emotions and allows you to then
react or respond to them and so just be
bold over and controlled by them so even
if you say you know something happens
and you get like furious at someone
normally without you know being
unexamined you would just jump into
whatever it is yelling at them or i
don't know what people do whenever they
get furious
but um
with you know being more
tuned into a mindful way of living that
would arise and then you really get to
address the root of that fury and that
anger in the first place it's an
important distinction to make because
obviously it's not useful to just
respond emotionally be crazy and out of
control and see red and do whatever
it's also not useful to completely play
and this gets into an interestingly
nuanced area of what you know of
mindfulness some would say spirituality
to not
look at that situation wherever you get
frustrated and go full on like okay i
noticed the arising feeling of
frustration i'm not going to respond to
it i'm going to you know exhale breathe
calmly and allow it to move on and just
let that move and then later
i'll engage with whoever the person was
you know if if it's still an issue and
discuss you know constructively what the
problem might be
um that also
if if not done well can be
you have danger of again passivity and
of compartmentalization
um and so
if you want to get to the root of the
matter you when it arises you can use
mindfulness to not react to it but then
to pause and actually really examine
like
the impulses what am i thinking what am
i why did i get so reactive like is this
something of mine that i'm being
triggered that is something i need to
work on is it something that i need to
create a boundary that they've you know
someone has done something to me that i
need to address and it helps you
actually get out like why you had that
reaction in the first place instead of
just getting swept up in the drama of
the emotion
bring that back for me someone has an
emotion arise
what what are some of the cues or the
the triggers or the practices that they
can use to just
build that mindfulness gap in before the
downstream how to deal with it what
what's the first step in that yeah the
first one again i think that the noting
thing is really valuable so you start
getting mad just recognize like okay
hold on i'm getting getting really
pissed off here let me just pause
you notice it and pause don't go
straight into action you know and this
is the same for a self-talk about being
sad or yeah anxious or
depressed or whatever exactly just
notice it's there and then and then
pause
and you can you know take a breath
create a little bit of space give
yourself time to actually catch up to
the flurry of what's happened and then
you can start the self-inquiry process
and realize you know what intentional
choice you need to make um
what i was going to get into earlier is
an interesting pretty
um tricky part of
the ever-evolving story of someone
living mindfully or more um
you know a quote-unquote spiritual
identity which i don't i'm not really
into that word or those words but it's
in terms of what people think about it
as
um
is that you can do all these practices
let's look at like the the maximum
optimal person who is
uh doing you know they're completely
non-reactive they're tranquil they're
peaceful you know they're they're doing
all this uh 24 7 never disrupted always
just super easy going
um
what can happen there interestingly is
that you can begin to feel like
you
you get stiff in this way to where you
can start out of the service of trying
to do these things so much
and
trying to almost play the character of
this person as you try and do this stuff
more
you can run the danger of actually
becoming
self-righteous in this way right
so
whenever you're you don't want to kind
of break the character and acknowledge
that you're actually a human being and
then you're actually feeling some of
these things
you're just you're you're living this
kind of calcified form of mindfulness
zombie and not allowing yourself to
acknowledge the truth of what's going on
deep inside of you and that is the trap
that people can fall into you know and
you start the self-righteousness is that
then you wear that character of being
the completely calm tepid person at all
times
around others and even with yourself and
that way you're like oh yeah no i'm
completely unaffected by all of you and
all of this you know you become a
prisoner of your own mindfulness exactly
exactly
and so whenever you do feel those things
you know and it says you know it answers
this question within itself is whenever
you feel the anger or whatever
oh no i'm just going to let that pass
and i'm not going to not well that's
great and you should not react to it but
if you aren't
engaged in it
then you're you're messing up because
you want to engage in well why did i
what happened there like why did i feel
that like what's going on what do i need
to understand more clearly about the
situation of myself or what should i be
saying or doing in this moment as
opposed to just always like you're
shutting it off right because that's one
of the miscommunications that people get
is they think
well
it that leads to a lot of resentment you
know of other people and and as i said
self-righteousness
because i've got so many messages from
people who are like hey so i've gotten
really good at disarming my reactive
anger towards my wife and kids or
whatever when they're being crazy and i
want to yell at them i've got that now
but now i feel resentful that i'm always
the one that's having to set aside my
my feelings and they're just totally
unexamined running wild and i'm just
dealing with it all and so now i'm
starting to feel irritated at them and
that's where you know as i said
self-righteous because now you're like
well now i'm the victim kind of the one
having to bear all of this
and these people are
inferior animals and now i'm i am
starting to dislike them because i'm
always having to offload the stuff
and
that's because the step one is stopping
the reactions and all that but step two
is actually examining
understanding why you're feeling that
why that button is being pushed and then
engaging and communicating with you know
the person of the people clearly
about what you're experiencing right so
if if you're you know if the kids are
running around screaming and breaking
stuff and you're feeling irritated and
you go okay let that go just be cool
move on go to another room
yeah you do that but then you also go
hey by the way you all need to calm down
and chill out and be whatever you know
tell give them i'm not a parent give
them whatever feedback you give to kids
i don't know but um but that's the point
and if you you move that into all the
areas of your life and that way it keeps
you from getting that resentment or that
weirdness or the righteousness and
actually again it's you know engagement
is so important you know in this stuff
one of the big misnomers that that's out
there is that people mistake
being more
tranquil and self-aware with passivity
you know because for a lot of various
reasons but they think it's almost this
kind of like disengagement with like no
i'm just going to like let things kind
of flow by it's not that at all you know
it's it's actually kind of the opposite
of that in a lot of ways is it stepping
out of the the
causal kind of flow of reactivity but
then stepping into
actually being present and engaged with
you know intentionality
triggers final
bits anything that you think that we
haven't got in order to bring that
mindfulness gap into the into daily life
any habits any routines any triggers any
cues that people should remember to use
if they want to try and really
instantiate this yeah i think a useful
one is looking for like little bits of
time in the day because you can practice
even just kind of like checking in with
your breathing just calming it down
checking your shoulders that's really
so much tension and the anxiety and
worry and all that stuff and that people
have
uh is just through on
being unaware of their own tension and
grasping so you kind of get tense you
start thinking your shoulders get tight
you know your brow gets tight your heart
starts racing if you take a moment to
just like go hold on a second let me
change my posture relax the shoulders
relax the face
and take some breaths kind of just calm
things down a little bit like that will
do so much for people it's it's crazy
but it's just having never thought to do
that is why no one hasn't done it before
but if you do think to do that it's on
the menu for you then you just find
these little spaces in your life whether
you're standing in line you're waiting
for something you're waiting for someone
to show up you're meeting them you have
five minutes or whatever even 30 seconds
you can re realign the posture relax the
the shoulders and the face and then
focus in on just taking a couple of
relaxing breaths and just tuning back in
again
and if you you do that consistently when
you find these little empty spaces in
your day
then what happens is that actually just
becomes a trained behavior over time so
like i do that without well i i'm aware
i'm doing it but i don't have to stop
and go okay i should do it now i just do
it and i'm like oh cool just going to
reset real quick and then move on none
if people spent
six months working on one habit one
mental cue trigger occurs i understand
the response you can move that from the
very deliberate system to to the
automated system one and i've done this
with a bunch of different things so the
stoic fork was one that i did it with
for a while where look do i have control
over this or not and that
now
for me is mostly automatic yeah it just
arises look i don't have control over it
so [ __ ] like it's a traffic jam i didn't
know that this was going it's raining i
didn't know that this was going to occur
the
power's gone off today i was supposed to
have a podcast and the wife i went off
in my airbnb
all right well i can't fix it i message
the person that does the airbnb i'm
going to go to the gym instead and
that's now automated
the number of times and i think that six
months is a
slow enough period for you to have okay
i have one goal i have one behavioral
goal that i want to try and move from
system to system one and if you can do
that
in five years time you are
unrecognizable you've just accumulated
and maybe after whatever a couple of
years you need to go back and do little
stints of some of the first ones you did
but man there's so much here and you
know from the first episode that we ever
did i think you're episode number nine
or twelve or something
um and this will be 410 but the
mindfulness gap which was the term that
i got from you
that now is still today one of the
things that i try and focus on something
arises inside of me and there is a beat
just a half second pause between
stimulus and response and that's power
i've said this over and over if the only
thing that i get out of meditation is
the ability to have that beat i'll
consider it a win yeah maybe some
greater levels of
flourishing and
meditative bliss would be would be nice
but that's enough of a win to make it
worthwhile to make the practice
worthwhile and i think that
trying to make it practical trying to
take it off the mat trying to go from
when you're doing your sits to okay now
how does this apply how does this make
my daily experience more effective i
think there's some
some awesome stuff in there for people
so
if people want to check out what you do
get the guided meditations do your other
stuff where should they go yep they go
to coreydashon.com and then hey corey
allen is all my social handles amazing
and the astral hustle that's the podcast
the astrologer yeah brother thank you
thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you